let's compare two-fourths and
three-fourths
first let's think about what these
fractions mean
two-fourths means we have some whole
and we've split it into four equal-sized
pieces and we get two of those pieces
maybe we can think about pizza for an
example we split a pizza into four equal
sized pieces and we ate two of them
three-fourths means that same whole that
same pizza was again split into four
equal sized pieces but this time what's
different is we got three of the pieces
so maybe from that description we can
start to think about which one is larger
but let's also let's draw them also
just to be sure
that we can decide which one is larger
so for two-fourths
we're going to have a fraction like
maybe it's a pizza and it's going to be
divided split into four
equal sized pieces
that may not these may not be perfect
lines but should represent four equal
sized pieces
and we get two
of those pieces
so this represents two two-fourths two
out of four
three-fourths again what will be the
same is the four equal-sized pieces
but this time we get three of the four
so one
two
three of the four pieces
and this will represent three-fourths
so now
we can look at it visually and see very
clearly that three-fourths is greater or
takes up more space
or we can say the 2 4 is less
than 3 4.
and remember this is the less than
symbol because we always want this open
bigger side facing our larger number and
in this case it's facing the the second
number
so we'll say two-fourths is less
than three-fourths
each of these fourths is the same size
so two of them is less than three of the
fourths
here we can try one more but this time
let's don't draw the picture let's just
think about what they mean and see if we
can figure it out
so for 5 8 we have a whole
and it's been divided into 8 equal
pieces
for 3 8 same thing 8 equal pieces
but here in 5 8 we get 5 of those pieces
and in 3 8 we get 3 of the pieces
so the pieces are the same size they're
eighths on both sides these are eights
and these are eights
but here we have five of the eights and
here we have three
so if the pieces are the same size
five pieces is greater than three pieces
or five eighths is greater than three
eighths
and here our open end our bigger side is
still facing our bigger number but our
bigger number is first this time so this
is the greater than symbol 5 8 is
greater
than 3 8.